giant cardboard robot arms and eyelashes
for your car it's episode 14 of loot
this optical mouse transforms into a
mechanical beast that can battle your
pick shaped desk vacuum be sure to team
it up with this USB flash drive and
here's a Chinese farmer who grows pairs
inside molds so they wind up looking
like little edible Buddhas this axe
appears to be going through your wall
but actually it's just perfect for
hanging up keys or a coat while you're
out in the Sun this summer be sure to
wear your solar-powered bikini that can
charge your phone and iPod or to be more
formal use these power icon cufflinks
with built-in LEDs that breathe like a
sleeping computer if you go to a summer
barbecue blend in by wearing cube a
cologne that smells like spices smoked
meat and sweet summer sweat and be sure
to bring your host a bottle of wine
topped with the Daddy wine puzzle an
infuriatingly difficult puzzle to open
that locks the bottles cork
well why eat boring hot dogs when you
could have a happy hot dog man this one
move slicer gives your tube meat limbs
and a face that you can decorate is that
too happy well roast your weenies with
this Cthulhu skull roaster instead oh
and don't forget corn which is much more
funner as a lightsaber corn come get
classy by tossing your summer salad in
this bowl that resembles a boat with
oars and of course if you insist on
eating clean food you should stick with
this hot dog it's actually an artfully
colored and molded bar of soap
finally serve vat19 unfortunate cookies
once the food coma sets in blow up your
necktie like a balloon and sleep on it
like a pillow these mugs from Nita rama
give you a fun animal nose when you
drink out of them but if you think
that's all just a bunch of monkey
business grab this mug with a built-in
motor that stirs itself as you ate add
Jesus to your morning waffles your
breakfast I'm sure followed a glorious
night's rest on your girlfriend's lap
shaped pillow or your boyfriend arm
pillow that hugs you when no one else is
around if you're a newborn baby watching
the program be sure to check out the
zakir disembodied hand pillows that
cradle you want to be weirder we'll take
a nap at the office inside the ostrich a
sensory deprivation sleeping sack you
can sling over your shoulder like a soft
luxurious bladder
now something free instructions from
Instructables on how to turn your old
boring appliances into a VHS toaster and
as always thanks for watching